hey everyone
welcome to the direct path number 13.
check out the other videos in the series
if you haven't yet
what we are doing in the series is we
are
showcasing the different faces
and paths and signposts on
the mountain to the one end
of enlightenment and the flatness
is the non-duality and the mountain
is the duality you already are the
diamond necklace that is around your
neck
yet it remains for you to recognize it
so jumping right in nondual dual
individuation
what does that mean true simultaneity
the non-duality the flatness the fact
that we are already it
the duality the fact that there is
something to seek there's something to
find there's someone to become
enlightened and the individual the
unique expression of the individual
ashrae arubindo said diversity and
oneness is the mathematics of the
infinite being able to hold all of these
layers simultaneously the dual
the non-dual the individual all
simultaneously and navigate
reality flawlessly as joseph in the code
of many colors to be able to
like a jedi have conversations with
people across
all of these different
interpretations all of these different
layers
so jumping right into the non-dual that
means not to that means simply this
appearance what is appearing right now
is a modulation of underlying energy as
quantum mechanics will say
and that that modulation is making an
appearance
of matter as physicalism as this reality
and there's an infinite amount of ways
for that energy to be modulated just
like there is an infinite amount of ways
for
music itself to be written and composed
and then to produce a song a universe a
one
song and symphonies don't play one song
they play many songs that is the
multiverse
that is why sir roger penrose has a
theory of cyclic cosmology now
the noble winner in physics in 2020
so even physics and science is beginning
to catch up to the perennial spiritual
wisdoms of things like the oroboros
the snake eating its tail and so simply
this
appearance is just this appearance
and that's it and there is no one to
become enlightened it's just this
appearance
and it's already unconditionally free
it's whole it's perfect it's an
exploration of infinity infinity is
using these dreamed realities to explore
and it's unbounded exploration so it's
eternal and it never ends that's what
this
is and also with non-duality you
recognize that awareness itself
is shared so there are not two agents
that are aware but there's only one
agent that is aware
that witness or observer that is aware
across all eight billion of us
is god that is awareness or
consciousness that is shared amongst all
eight billion of us in just this
creation design as well as all of the
other creation designs
all of the other dreams
so non-duality is piercing the veilless
veil
hiking up the flat mountain the
bubbleless bubble the pathless path the
gateless gate
and recognizing that our awareness is
shared and it is eternal
again that is the diamond necklace
already around her neck yet it remains
for us to recognize
it and again the non-dual is also the
absolute it's the ineffable it's the
dreams
so there's nothing to be able to say
it's just
this non-dual appearance it's just this
non-dual dream
and it's beautiful and it's incredible
and it's ineffable
in its eternal fireworks that are
happening
here in this creation design as well as
what's been happening before what's
happening after
just eternal fireworks
and then you go to the dual
you go to the two and what you recognize
there
is that you have both ignorance and you
have knowledge
so you have this mountain you have
people that are in the contracted egoic
separate self-finite energy and then you
have people that are literally
bathing in the hot tea of infinity
and then you have that egoic sugar cube
that dissolves over time
like in the parable of the prodigal son
it comes back to
consciousness it comes back to awareness
to god realization
and the contracted sugar cube dissolves
into the hot tea
of infinity and so that's ignorance
ignorance is maya ignorance is the
intoxication
of thinking that you're going to find
peace and happiness inconspicuous
consumption
in fame in materialism in rolexes and
yachts and private jets and chanel and
gucci and [ __ ] like that
and in the non-dual perspective it's all
just
this appearance so even the egoic
contracted separate finite entity that
goes out into the world
seeking the intoxicative pleasures of
maya
is still whole and perfect and exactly
what it is but in the dualistic
concession here
what you say is that that's ignorance
and knowledge is when you come back to
awareness or consciousness
as fundamental reality and that then
from
there it becomes an effortless action a
woo way as you artistically go outward
and express yourself so you're no longer
chasing the intoxicative pleasures of
maya
rather you are simply honing in on the
architecting of the social fabric to
become more and more prosperous and
abundant for everybody
and that's what's meant by the planetary
mystic teachings mysticism means union
which is what yoga means which is what
hinosis means union with what with the
absolute with god
and so that's why the perennial wisdoms
teach mysticism they teach how to become
one with the
ineffable with the absolute with god and
this is what sq means which is the
spiritual quotient
as you have iq you also have eq
emotional quotient you also have sq
spiritual quotient you also have dq the
digital quotient
which we'll talk about here in a bit
knowledge in the dualistic concession is
also god realization again that is when
you go all the way inward to recognize
awareness of awareness itself you become
aware of being aware
you recognize that that awareness is
eternal and it is shared
and it's also the densities of ascension
like you see in the law of one in our
video that we did on that as well
within these dreams especially when you
look at things like
the
the things like the law of conservation
of energy
and what you see is you see that even
within this dream itself
that the energy that's modulated within
the dream itself
is what appears to be this atlas unit
and what appears to be this audience
units
and that that's why within these
densities of ascension
in just this dream why it feels like or
it appears like
there is an atlas character that's been
working on its
soul angle that has been evolving from
the lower densities
and that has had to experience what it's
like to be
a rock and to be a plant and to be an
animal and now to be a human
and next to evolve to love and next to
evolve to love and wisdom
and then to evolve to love and wisdom
and light
and that then at the very end of that
ascension process
upon achieving an enlightened
civilization
upon going through that process for
millennia century slash millennia
as we also experienced the transcension
hypothesis of going inward into the
metaverse
that there is a
the end of the dream of this density of
ascension
and then the beginning of the next
density of ascension
so as though the next density of
ascension
it may not have this atlas unit it may
not have those audience units but
all of the energy may be modulated
differently
as a different musical harmonic as a
different
artistic palette so that the idea of a
soul the idea of a soul
angle the idea of the
law of conservation of energy the idea
of the
individual being something that ascends
over time
in this density with their own unique
soul
angle like in this case i'm very much
like joseph in the code of many colors
with the breadth
and polymethy and synthesis and
distillation like michelangelo
that that may change in the next density
this may be a completely different unit
of expression of infinity
and so may yours and so it's important
to recognize that densities of ascension
portion as well
because it's basically this dreamed
reality design across
all of the lifetimes of the soul angle
developing here
and then again at the gateway at the
highest of the octaves
what happens is right there at the last
density
what you do is you drop at the seventh
you drop everything that you've learned
you surrender everything to the infinite
and boom you go through the eighth
density through the gateway back into
the first density of the next stream
and you may actually be a different soul
angle a different
energetic modulation expression slash
artistic combinatoric of
infinity when you enter into the next
density
when you enter into the next dreamed
reality design
at the first density of that dreamed
reality design
and you work your way again up that
octave vibratory
that in itself is really interesting
because it's a synthesis of non-duality
with the densities
of ascension in the law of one and it's
also a synthesis
on david hawkins levels of consciousness
and
claire graves don beck and chris cohn
and ken wilbur's
spiral dynamics as well because there is
an awakening there is an
enlightenment there is an evolution
there is a ascension
and then there also is the non-dual
which is the recognition of the eternal
and so it's as though the map of the
non-dual
expresses and explains the eternal the
infinite whereas the maps of the
evolution of consciousness the maps of
the dualistic concession
they explain what is appearing in this
dream
and it's likely the same across other
dreams where there is a process of
infinite veiling itself which is the
coolest feature and mechanism that we
have
and then to pierce that veil and to
awaken
so for consciousness to awaken to its
own nature
and that's what walter russell meant by
the rhythmic balanced interchange and
andy bittner was really critical
for me to understand what that means
because
as you see in the taijitu you have both
the monism
and you have the dualism with the yin
yang in one symbol
and that's very similar with when you
take the two poles
and then you put them into a rhythmic
balanced interchange just like an
electromagnetism
just like in the solenoid just like in
that helical spiral
of ascension and it's going up towards
an attractor which is a
mathematical
what a complex system evolves towards
mathematically
and that that's what this is it's a
symphonic style
ascension between two poles in rhythmic
balanced interchange whether it be night
and day or male and female
and all of the little spectrum in
between when you have dawn and dusk
and where you have all the other
intersexual expressions in biology
and you have indigeneity and you have
modernity and you have capitalism and
you have socialism you have the west and
you have the east and you have the
individual and you have the collective
and you have the left in the u.s
politics and the right in the u.s
politics and what you do with these all
these polls all these dualisms
is you understand they're in a rhythmic
balanced interchange and you
synthesize them into one and you drain
the dirty bathwater like
an algorithm what you do is you archive
all of the codes that no longer serve us
and you uplift the beautiful
baby out of the dirty bathwater and you
merge them together into one
so algorithmically we must understand
how to extract what codes are working
from capitalism what codes are working
from socialism
and hyper accentuate them just like with
the east and the west just like with the
individual in the collective just like
with indigenating modernity
just like with the left and the right
politically in the u.s
just like with every single one of the
expression of the two poles in a
harmonic flux
rhythmic balanced interchange towards
the godhead attractor
in the oroboros and so that's the
dualism
and then you have the individuation the
individuation is the not
divisible that's what individual means
not divisible
and that's why infinity expressing
itself
is the non-dual expressing itself as the
dualistic rhythmic balanced interchange
as ignorance that is seeking knowledge
and as
the multiplicity as the individuality
which is the final unit
there is no dividing after the
individual
the individual is the final unit now you
can go down and say
oh but what about all of these cells in
each one of the 30 trillion cells that
the individual is made out of yes
and then each one of those cells is made
up of a bunch of
molecules and each one of those
molecules is made up of a bunch of
atoms and each one of those atoms is
made up of different subatomic particles
and then those are made up of quarks and
those are made up of
plonks and then you just keep going down
and so the idea is that
the plonks and the corks and the
subatomic particles and the
atoms and the molecules and the cells
those
all constitute the final unit which is
the individual
the individual is the final unit there's
no dividing beyond this unit
or beyond your individuated unit
that is what infinity uses to express
itself
are these units and it uses
the energetic modulations at the level
of the subatomic particles
in order to express these last
individuated units
and this is what is known as the unique
expression this is the art
this is where infinity uses these units
to god actualize so
as you god realize and you recognize
your infinitude the ineffable the
absolute
you then woo way effortlessly go
outward from the highest morality and
you weave like the tantric path like
sahaja samadhi
like the goldilocks zone like buddha's
middle way what you do
like ramana maharshi sahaja samadhi
and you go outward and you weave your
profound realizations into your daily
activities
and so that is the
highest god actualization the highest
individuated expression of infinity
is when the individuated expression of
infinity
understands its own true metaphysics its
own true nature
and then it flawlessly harmonically
effortlessly expresses itself
artistically
there is no ego there is no breaking
point that happens there
is no narcissism there's no jealousy
there's no conspicuous consumption
there's no greed
there's no self dealing there's none of
that because you
understand your own true nature and how
your own true nature
is our true nature
and that's why we write the optimization
of iq eq
and dq because the more that you
optimize in terms of knowing having a
high
when you have a high intelligence
quotient
what you're doing is you're able to
parse and identify
patterns like a god around
especially things like the golden ratio
1.618 you're able to understand the
pattern recognition kind of like
artificial intelligence and machine
learning sees if you can catch those
algorithms
fast among society how to be an optimal
entrepreneur how to be an optimal artist
how to have the highest emotional
intelligence out of high
have high empathy how to have high
ability to navigate the meta
communicative para language the
navigation of status and clout the
gesticulation the non-verbal cues the
non-lexical cues all of this type of
stuff
and we just made a video on nunchi
covering that as well
and then also the dq the digital
quotient how well do you know how to use
the mass media platforms that are modern
do you know how to make
viral tick tock videos do you know how
to create
profound instagram stories do you know
how to
make a vlog do you know how to conduct a
thought-provoking interview do you know
how to
run a youtube channel do you know how to
make a thought-provoking twitter thread
do you know how to do things like that
do you know how to ask the best
questions possible and so
once you know how to also god actualize
from the absolute highest iq eq
and dq along with the sq of the god
realization then you're absolutely
unstoppable
you know the non-dual you know the dual
and you know the individual
and that's what direct path number 13 is
about it's the non-dual dual
individual it's holding all of these
layers simultaneously
like sri aurobindo said diversity in
oneness is the mathematics of the
infinite
so oneness is the non-dual the absolute
ineffable
and then you have the dualism which is a
concession
which is the ignorance that is
seeking enlightenment knowledge
and the rhythmic balanced interchange
between two poles
and then you have the individuation and
the individuation is the multiplicity
again it's illusory but it's the exact
beautiful way that
infinity expresses itself creatively
and to recognize that truly and to be
able to optimize yourself on an iq
eq and dq level around
the flawless harmonic effortless wu
way highest morality sahaja samadhi
tantric path of weaving your
realizations into the social fabric
to maximize human potential that is it
that is it
there's nothing more beyond being able
to navigate these layers simultaneously
to hold the true simultaneity of all of
these layers
simultaneously non-duality duality
and individual the non-dual dual
individual
all of them simultaneously like a
[ __ ] jedi
that's it it's as simple as that
so again the diamond necklace is already
around each of our necks that's the
non-duality
and the dualistic concession is to say
that
i don't see the diamond necklace around
my neck i'm still
seeking happiness and peace externally
and it's to turn
inward like the parable of the prodigal
son to recognize
awareness consciousness as the god
realization
as the diamond necklace around the neck
and then the individuation
is the source light refracting through
your own unique
jewel around your neck as the artistic
expression
of infinity out into the finite dream
that this is
non-dual dual individuation adore you so
much
thank you for tuning in it's so
fascinating being able to
juggle all of these concepts inside of a
lattice work
that is attempting to
make the ineffable be represented by
symbols in a cohesive way by story in a
cohesive way by
art in a cohesive way that helps people
both
god realize and god actualize and to
make
pedagogy around this in a non-dogmatic
non-fundamental way
in a way that is beautiful and blissful
and peaceful and collaborative and
harmonic with
our planetary ecology and one another
so if the video brought you value like
the video subscribe if you haven't
share the video with other people that
you know this would profoundly resonate
with
and comment below and let me know how
you feel would love to hear from you
and join the channel if you want to gain
exclusive perks and become a member
every single one of the dollars of
revenue goes directly into the
actualization of all of our biggest
projects we adore you so much
thank you for all of your support
infinite love
and the non-dual dual
individuation so beautiful
true simultaneity across all layers
joseph and the code of many colors
tailored like a jedi
at all times
thank you
namaste i bow to the divine in you